mientras los contagios por kobe 19
siguen rompiendo récords casi diario
aquí en el reino unido- del gobierno ha
empezado a trabajar en planes de
contingencia ante la posibilidad de que
hasta un 25 por ciento de los empleados
del sector público no pueda cumplir con
sus funciones o por tener el virus o por
estar en un periodo de aislamiento
el primer ministro boris johnson ha
pedido prepararse para el peor escenario
por el aumento de casos aún mayor que se
espera en las primeras semanas de este
2022 este llamado también se ha
extendido a la empresa privada se teme
especialmente bajas de empleados clave
que no puedan trabajar desde la casa
como el personal de la salud y es que
desde que arrancó esta avalancha de
casos de la variante omicron hemos visto
constantemente en el país el aumento de
bajas de personal como de policía de
bomberos de empleados de la salud de
profesores y constantemente se están
cancelando servicios del tren justamente
por esto
el personal está enfermo o está en
periodo de aislamiento pese al panorama
que se vive hoy aquí en el reino unido-
de las advertencias de los científicos y
de los expertos el gobierno por ahora no
contempla imponer nuevas restricciones
para tratar de frenar estos contagios de
kobe 19 en el país